on march 27 2020 one web
filed for bankruptcy a couple of months
later
the uk government and an indian
conglomerate named bharath enterprises
would bail out one web pitching in 500
million each
this bailout attracted additional
investment into one web
which will likely keep the company alive
for a few more years
but with juggernauts like spacex amazon
apple and even facebook competing in the
space why is oneweb
even trying before we get into the video
let's make it clear that none of us want
to see one web fail
competition and multiple options in the
market is always a good thing for the
consumer
with that being said though one web's
chances in the satellite internet
business
aren't the best so let's take a look at
how oneweb got to where they are today
and why they're at a massive
disadvantage oneweb
was originally founded in 2012 with the
name world vue
at the start the company was actually
quite conservative
as they simply looked to launch 20
satellites operating at 20 different
orbital planes
one of the most significant factors
going for one web in the early days
was the theme behind it most of the
early employees were extremely talented
individuals who left google to try
growing
their own company talent wasn't their
only advantage though
one web was also quickly building up
partnerships with leaders in the space
in november of 2014 news broke that one
web was trying to secure a partnership
with spacex the companies were looking
to build a factory together that could
produce high-volume low-cost satellites
no deal would go through though likely
because of musk's vision for starlink
since one web couldn't form a deal with
spacex they would put out the satellite
manufacturing contract in the market
and they would garner bids from a couple
of notable companies including airbus
and lockheed martin in the meantime one
web would also onboard a couple of
notable investors
including the version group and qualcomm
these new partners and investments would
allow one web to significantly scale up
their satellite vision
to 720 satellites in orbit by the end of
softbank would invest as well pouring in
a massive 1 billion dollars
and grabbing a 40 stake in the company
at the time
all of this hype seemed justified in
february of 2017
one web announced that they had already
sold nearly all of their communication
capacity
so one web would further expand their
plans to add another 1972 satellites
everything was just plans though one web
was yet to launch a single satellite
this however would change in february of
2019 when oneweb launched six test
satellites on the soyuz rocket
after this test launch though one web
wouldn't do another launch for an entire
year
with the next launch occurring in
february of 2020 they would go ahead and
do one more launch march of 2020
but as we discussed at the beginning
this is when they would file for
bankruptcy
the pandemic introduced massive
uncertainty within the investment world
and oneweb's investors were reluctant to
porn more money
one web did try their best to avoid
bankruptcy by significantly cutting back
on their workforce
going from 531 employees to just 74.
this was of course not enough though
fortunately for one web
they would get a bailout and as
uncertainty about the pandemic loose end
their initial investors would pour in
additional funding this funding
has allowed them to complete a couple
more launches bringing up the total
operational satellite count to 176
one web anticipates that they almost
have enough funding to launch their
entire 648 gen1 satellite fleet
right now they are about 300 million
short
but they don't think raising this money
will be an issue so
that's basically the state of one web
today they've made a significant
recovery since their bankruptcy
and it looks like their first set of
satellites will be fully operational
within the next couple of years
that's the good part unfortunately
there's bad parts too
with the first being a lack of leverage
the main competitors in the satellite
internet business
are of course spacex and blue origin and
they both have
massive leverage as for spacex their key
point of leverage
is vertical integration they make their
own satellites
they make their own rockets and they
launch their own rockets nearly every
single step along the way
is controlled completely by spacex which
significantly reduces cost
as they cut out the middlemen with one
web on the other hand
they're a middleman in everything they
don't make their own satellites
they don't make their own rockets and
they don't conduct their own launches
they rely on other companies or
countries to accomplish all of this for
them
which surely costs much more this lack
of vertical integration will basically
make it impossible for one web to
compete against darling's pricing
something else to consider is that one
web also doesn't have a massive fan base
or mission that millions of people
around the world resonate with spacex is
trying to colonize mars
and i'm sure that a significant
proportion of the satellite internet
market
will choose spacex over the competition
just to support their mission
as for blue origin amazon jeff bezos was
also trying to take the vertically
integrated route
but recently amazon announced that they
were going to rely on ula to launch
their first set of satellites
it looks like jeff bezos still wants to
use blue origin for launches
in the future however they're settling
with ula in the meantime
to prevent spacex from building too
large of a lead this
doesn't really matter though as amazon's
point of leverage was never vertical
integration
amazon's key leverage is their massive
prime subscriber base
who love their services and love their
customer support even more
while i'm sure space enthusiasts will
almost always pick spacex over amazon
i'm not sure the average person really
cares and it's very likely that amazon
can find large success within this
demographic
which is just looking for the most
convenient option
so unlike their competitors oneweb
doesn't really have strong leverage
within the market
more importantly though one web can't
afford to fail
their near-death experience during the
pandemic basically proves its point
you guys may have heard about facebook
and apple and other large corporation's
ambitions to compete against spacex
and amazon these slate entrants have
similar shortfalls to one web
they don't have manufacturing capability
or advanced rocket technology
but what they do have is the ability to
fail
apple has roughly 200 billion dollars in
cash and facebook has about 65 billion
in cash so neither company would really
be hurt by burning a couple billion
or even 10 billion dollars on trying to
launch their own satellite internet
if they do succeed though the reward
would be quite large
meaning that their risk to reward ratio
is extremely favorable
spacex also has massive margins to fail
i mean just take a look at how many
times starship prototypes had to explode
before spacex nailed the landing the
thing is investors are much more okay
with burning money on revolutionary
rocket technology that could take us to
mars
with one web though if the constellation
doesn't generate enough demand
or if they have some sort of technical
failure within their constellation
i'm not sure how long investors would
realistically stick around for
and that brings us into the last major
disadvantage for one web
which is an ugly track history when i
say that one web has an ugly track
history
i'm not referring to one web
specifically but rather the satellite
internet business
in general satellite internet is not a
new idea by any means companies have
been trying to launch satellite internet
but failing for decades at this point
a perfect example of this is tadasak
teledesac was actually a project backed
by bill gates and mobile tycoon craig
mccaw
way back in the 1990s given the people
behind the project
talodesek was easily able to breeze past
funding and regulation
however after seeing lackluster demand
for satellite services
teledesk was shut down in the early
2000s similarly
uranium communications was a satellite
service business that filed for
bankruptcy in 1999
well before the dot-com bubble even
burst they are still around today
but they haven't really made any money
over the last 22 years
another satellite business that flopped
is global star and there are several
more notable examples
considering the checkered past of the
satellite services industry
many people doubt that even spacex and
amazon can successfully pull off
satellite internet
whether they do or not there's no doubt
that's been a tough journey for them as
well
this uncertainty is simply magnified
when we take a look at a startup like
oneweb
and why it seems like one web doesn't
even have a chance
while all that criticism is completely
fair and accurate
there are a couple of factors going for
one web such as their self-awareness
oneweb knows that competing against
spacex and amazon in the consumer
industry
where brand image is extremely important
is basically futile
that's why they're not targeting this
market in march of 2021
oneweb announced that their primary
target audience was businesses
governments phone network operations and
clusters of communities
by avoiding the large consumer market
oneweb is largely able to avoid
competing in spacex and
amazon directly moreover by targeting
commercial customers
oneweb can reduce their customer base to
a few customers who pay a lot
which will likely be much easier to
handle than 10 million mainstream
consumers
at the end of the day one web doesn't
really shine in any one category
they don't have vertical integration or
a moving mission or tens of billions to
burn through
the history of satellite businesses
failing also doesn't bode too well for
them
hopefully by concentrating on niche
commercial customers which the big
players aren't that interested in
one web will find some success but we'll
just have to wait and see
do you guys think oneweb has a chance
comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys hope oneweb
succeeds and of course consider joining
our discord community to suggest for
your video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one